let me see your phone whoa who's
touching who's texting you going stick
say you know him
Aaron Club what counts is cheating is it
ever okay how do you talk about it do
you ever come back from it commenting on
someone else's Instagram cheating no
okay letting a girl grab your junk on
the dance floor like if you dancin she
grabbing your junk and you were like
movement away be like hey that's more
than I'm comfortable not you think
that's yeah but if you know you butter
jerk you off on the dance machine if it
feels like you're cheating you probably
is if you cheat on someone never tell
them because you're punishment for
cheating on someone is that you have to
keep that burden on oh like you have to
live with that guilt and I like telling
someone you're actually just doing
yourself a favor and maybe mess yeah Wow
if some cheating is happening it's
probably like this indicative of some
deeper problems so like I used to keep
it in I say tell the person so I
remember one time after a comedy show in
Chicago I was out with my friends Ariel
was asleep I was we were all dancing a
group and then I was like dancing with
this one girl two people get a little
closer and like I talked about it
afterwards like then you've got a hole
to close on the dance floor
yeah Amy uncomfortable did she
appreciate this yes you know she
appreciated that we were talking about
it see have you ever cheated on anyone
1 2 3 sure do it again in a heart oh no
he deserved it I was in a really really
bad relationship yeah he was very
manipulative very emotionally abusive
and I as a strong as independent woman
still couldn't get out you want to break
up with him didn't really know how
because he was so possessive and
emotionally manipulative so I just
wasn't changing um make him agree with
you now what about if you get cheated on
the closest thing I have to that was
like I had a relationship with the girl
was kind of like on-again off-again and
then she's like calls me is like yo I
totally just found this dude and I was
like okay well that doesn't make me feel
good
- on-again off-again relationships are
always messy because that blurs the line
of not only your relationship within
what you can and can't do now let me ask
you this do you think once a cheater
always a cheater whoo I think cheating
is so much an outgrowth of what's
happening in the relationship that know
if you've seen it before there's hope
hi I'm hope and I'm sure there are some
people out there they're just sleaze
balls and they're always gonna be sleaze
balls we call them [ __ ] boys in summary
if you're cheating Kelsey says hold it
in I say talk about with your partner
and if you're getting cheated on I'm
sorry
I've been very sorry you're better than
them well except on my situation where I
was better than them
[Music]